Liberals are delighted as Trump's been
indicted just a few hours ago the
Manhattan Grand Journey voted to indict
former president Donald Trump that makes
him the first former U.S president ever
to be charged for a crime well breaking
some glass ceilings there
of course the case centers around Trump
allegedly paying hush money to porn star
Stormy Daniels way back in 2016 a
mediocre porn star to be clear
I mean really star is a little strong
actress okay
a case Federal prosecutors had already
dropped but somehow it's back but will
economic woe still lead to Trump 2.0
because as Joe Biden wilts Trump's
campaign is going full tilt a recent Fox
News poll found inflation to be the
biggest concern among voters followed by
running out of balance of nature
capsules
three quarters of registered voters say
inflation caused some hardship over the
last six months it's true Larry can
barely afford to feed his koi fish
other koi fish
he feeds his koi fish other koi fish and
we got it yeah that's expensive as for
the economy in general a whopping 77
rated negativity negatively
they wanted to give it an even worse
rating but they couldn't afford it
when told of the American public's
hardship abiding family spokesman said a
few million bucks from Chinese
businesses will help soften the blow
oh man meanwhile Mr Trump's lead over
his potential Rivals just continues to
grow indictment or not a new National
survey found more than 50 percent of
Republican primary voters prefer Trump
to anyone else the only one who prefers
Trump more of course is this political
genius
is what they call a dweeb and Trump is
the one who needs to get the nomination
because then the Democrats will win he's
a two-time loser already hello
loser of course when she said hello
loser everyone in the views audience
responded what
Joy reminds me of that old saying about
stopped clocks because they also have
stupid useless faces
foreign
's economy cools off like a forgotten
bowl of his morning mush and Trump's
campaign heats up like a fresh taco bowl
from Trump Tower Grill
might we be heading for a 2020 rematch I
wonder what Joe thinks
he pulls
come on who's gonna be these guys are
these guys you know so uh oh look I
noticed something
every day something happens
and if I pay attention to that thing I
don't have to pay attention to all the
other things so come on man play ball
hey buy me some crackers and peanut
snacks
no that's a fact Jack yes
2024 nominee hey
all right Larry I haven't heard your
opinion on the breaking news what say
you about the indictment
well you know the grand jury wasn't
supposed to be meeting today yeah so
this kind of strikes me as a sort of Old
Line Soviet style prosecution I don't
think they had the goods on him I mean I
think the lawyer uh Bob Costello just
destroyed Michael Cohn who was a
convicted perjurer I'm not in the grand
jury I'm not in the courtroom I'm
certainly not an attorney I haven't
covered this the way Shannon has but I
find it an unbelievable Story I mean the
grand jury is supposed to be out for
another month and then all of a sudden
so okay big fake out he's got it we'll
see how this plays out
um I don't think Bragg has the goods and
I think when the trial comes Trump is
going to be uh let off that's what I
think and then just publicity and just
politics Greg that's what I think you
know I hope what do you Iris you sent me
a chilling text when this broke would
you care to elaborate you don't have to
mention the text but yes I have been
working out though thank you yeah
I thought I said you need to work out
uh
today was an ugly blow like we all need
to remember this date this is this was
an ugly day a former president was
charged for being a man
listen I'm not the president what
oh this is what men do when we okay yeah
I could be the manager of Dunkin Donuts
okay and maybe I had an affair with I
don't know a fans only person I gave her
free donuts for free views and then she
decided to tell on me and so the new guy
I said listen you want free coffee and
Munchkins and all the jelly donuts you
want could you pay her this free stuff
and tell her to go away for me because I
don't want to get in trouble because my
wife's gonna kill me yeah and he does it
and he gets caught and he gets fired
that's it just being a guy has to do
with being a president no man who has an
affair
doesn't want to cover it up unless he's
an idiot like if he didn't cover it up I
wouldn't have voted for him if he would
have been like
if he would have came home to the Trump
Tower
and as he went down the escalator
are you running for president yes and I
cheated on my wife with a porn star
I'd be like
you know what Romney's not so bad
Romney would have put the porn star on
top of the car right
all right I'm proud of that one all
right Shannon I didn't think you'd
that's tough analysis to follow but you
I mean you've been talking about what's
your what's your uh what's your
well it brings to mind my brand new book
love stories of the Bible speak no this
is
sure but listen the fed's passed on this
as you said they looked at Prosecuting
this and decided they didn't have a case
they weren't going to go for it so for a
local prosecutor to pick it up listen
he's got a lot on the line we often joke
about grand juries will indeed a ham
sandwich that's the first part of this
but to get to a unanimous jury here in
New York on these charges that legal
Scholars across the Spectrum including
many on the far left and many
progressives say this is a bad move it's
a unique legal Theory that's not going
to work and it's only going to serve to
help former president Trump make the
case right that you're after him the
establishments after him the Deep States
after him so if they don't land a
conviction on this it goes in his win
column in more ways it validates
everything he said about being a a proxy
Target for voters I mean when you when
you put that along with you know uh you
know parents being called domestic
terrorists all these people imprisoned
over January 6. it Republicans and Trump
supporters are being hunted that's what
it seems to be saying why do they always
say they can indict a ham sandwich well
all it could happen but I mean like what
does that mean it's like you're gonna
die in anything you want remember with a
grand jury you don't have the same rules
of evidence that you do for Witnesses
and stuff actually in trial so you can
bring in a whole lot more stuff and you
know that can sway people I would never
indict a ham sandwich especially in New
York are you saying that because there's
a lot of Jews Larry how dare you
it's the second person that's made an
episode
Larry I love ham sandwiches New York
juries that worry me
and I think that's what Shannon's
getting at yes I mean look this thing
um I I don't want to take up some space
I'm just I'm annoyed because Bragg and
the grand jury people in the courts said
that the jury was out for a month so
they lied turns out the jury was meeting
okay fine but don't lie to me like that
and that's why I say that it is a
soviet-style approach they had to do
this in the in the dead of the non-day
they put it out at five o'clock in the
afternoon at five and nobody nobody knew
anything about this before so and I
think you're right it winds up helping
Trump politically yeah because he wants
to upset the establishment and this is
these crazy lefties this is nothing but
socialism for the 800th power but cat
you know what this does this validates
the conversation that we had like two
weeks ago with Russell Brand here
he's outside they're inside it's no
longer left and right it's outside
inside he was he's now he's now the
Renegade
well I also just
I think he's kind of always presented
himself that way he kind of has been
that I think he likes to be that so he
gets to say yeah you know I gotta look
there after me they're after me and then
if nobody nobody comes and gets you then
you kind of looks like you don't know
what you're talking about so I mean even
we saw him in Waco kind of talking about
this and he was you know firing up the
crowd talking about this and especially
because no other president or former
president has had this happen and it's
only been him so he's he's this you know
a martyr of sorts that's face these
things that are completely unique and he
taught he does that very very well that
there's nothing that fires up people
more than that so I I also it's just I
don't see how you could actually get
convicted here based on what's actually
there I don't but I think that you have
to know that I mean I even go I didn't
even go to law school I've just watched
a lot of Law and Order
um and I don't see how it's possible but
what is possible is that it could go on
for months and months and possibly even
into next into 2024 more all he needs is
one man on that jury
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else